[Music]
an american engineer is still held
captive by the taliban two years later
i hope he was a civil engineer he was he
was a civil engineer doing work for uh
the afghani people good cause if it was
a software engineer i think the taliban
would be like make a virus
so what are they saying instead
make a bridge
but we got a norton anti-virus right
that still works it doesn't work or
maybe he's like you need to hack them
you need to hack them that was that one
wasn't it funny though when they came
out with a statement condemning the
invasion he goes guys this is no time
for war
that's russian but like oh it's russia
remember when he was
all the taliban said yeah they mean the
[ __ ] ukraine innovation they're
saying they're waving the finger at them
yeah they're seeing it with the with the
russian
you should say that because yeah the
taliban is trying to legitimize
themselves yeah and uh so they've had
this guy captive for two years
um and a lot of the criticism from other
countries are like hey you guys are
never going to be legit if you keep this
prisoner like let him go already what if
they have a live stream and they're
treating him so well sounds like a north
korean thing
that's that's the way to do it i mean
americans took nazis to help us so yeah
like that's how we had the space program
for our science our science is so good
dude yeah our cia they were like into
like cancer research like they were like
really heavy like trying to create
cancer did they like get
pieces of land here as well in order to
like live like
a native american that doesn't work
american
uh i don't know what you're asking like
like a nazi reservation yeah like did
they get like no they've gotten into the
highest [ __ ] positions of government
and [ __ ] it's called operation paper
clip not even a [ __ ] conspiracy it's
open to disclosed [ __ ] like then that's
what the title winner von braun founded
nasa and he was a huge nazi he was nancy
yeah the guy from october sky it is kind
of interesting did he come up with a
rocket
no he found he just was the founder of
nasa he was like the guy at the top of
the chain but yeah point is the taliban
need to be able to allow somebody to get
to the top of the chain if they're going
to take them captive that's true
they have one condition on releasing
this guy what do you think it is
okay you must juggle with four balls
which is really four is really hard
because they've never seen four yeah
they're like what they're like i will
let you go
at four balls
and do you think they show him a video
of like another guy doing it like see
you
it can be done it's impossible what's
wrong with this guy some guy just
dropping it
do you have to go to the circle method
when it's four
you just got to keep it right what i
know is you have two balls and then it
they're actually like this
you big in a juggler
there's something disturbing about that
can you show us again like this two
balls
two you don't have to juggle two balls
or holding them
any other reasons they'd let this
sausage go i'm gonna go with the four
ball juggling that's it i think that's a
good answer i'm gonna say they want to
see a magic trick
that's true he doesn't have his plastic
thumb though how's he gonna do it they
probably just need to be um
a uh kind of like a spokesperson or the
face of some sort of propaganda campaign
i'll let you go
but you have to say we treated you
nicely what if he was like all right you
have to get my instagram page to 10 000
followers
help me with my my brand what if they're
like you need to figure out a way for us
to smuggle drugs between countries
like i cannot call judges
we need a new way to do this
that's the closest answer there are
rumors to a new way steve's the closest
but yeah here's a video that just uh
surfaced of that hostage um
basically pleading they released this
video right here tonight for the family
of a lombard man kidnapped in
afghanistan two years ago please
release me
release me so that i may be reunited
with my family his acting is great
this new video of mark frarix was
obtained damn he looks like he aged in
it he claims it was filmed back in
november ferrix was working as an
engineering contractor in kabul when the
taliban kidnapped him in january of
2020. his family is now urging president
biden to help bring him home
doing a magic trick yeah the dove i saw
it there it is yeah so his family's
pretty pissed at the bite administration
not doing more to like get him out of
there it's been two years and the thing
that they uh the taliban said they'll um
exchange him for
they want
spam
spam yeah they want
spam
he looks like clay from sons of anarchy
he's a cool looking dude but yeah the um
they want america to release an afghani
drug kingpin being held in a new
hampshire prison oh [ __ ] they want their
drug kingpin back
what do you guys think
do you think that's a fair trade
they want to release this guy wow that
guy looks scary anybody who has kingpin
in their name that sounds gangster
there's got to be a better picture of
him than that man what does he sell like
opium or like heroin he was a drug
trafficker opium's their biggest crop
there oh dude he i he imported 50
million dollars worth of heroin into new
york
god damn wow damn he's not a small fry
that's tough so they they want to do a
little trading trade that's that's a
that's a tough trade we're like
definitely uh you know selling the dip
when the taliban got your back like that
that's crazy
come on bro he's one of us maybe he
helps fund them
probably
if he got caught once don't you think he
can't go back to america and do it again
that's gonna everyone's gonna know who
he is here's what sounds funny it's like
his name is bashir nurzai and he's at
this point he's already served 17 years
he's an old dude that can't really do
anything do you think they just want to
get him to kill him because he turned
informant after oh you're [ __ ] me oh
oh that's petty that's crazy how it's
petty dude
he uh he cooperated with the government
by providing intelligence and helping
recover weapons from the taliban for
years so why did you tell us that he
wanted he had to do a magic trick or
some [ __ ]
i i'm just a copperfield fan okay
i mean he was he made a dove up here a
white dove you know to be fair before
you added that informant information a
part of me wanted to side with the idea
of trading
making that trade regardless so you're a
taliban supporter we do not negotiate
with terrorists yeah we don't negotiate
with terrorists i love how quickly you
can be re-categorized uh it's just kind
of a meme i guess i think biden would
negotiate with terrorists well they do
do they
do the iran under the table is that what
biden tells the family he's like can you
get my dad out we do not negotiate with
terrorists
and he's like oh [ __ ] he's like yeah
that's pretty much rather than you know
obviously like publicly say like maybe
we'll trade they're not they're not
addressing any of that but they are
publicly saying
come on taliban this isn't you anymore
like you guys are trying to be a legit
government
you got to just let him go so that you
could start from like you know being a
legitimized it's turning a new leaf yeah
right so like we see that you want your
kingpin back but come on you're trying
to turn new leaf anyway just let the guy
go right yeah we do not negotiate
returns they actually have been letting
people go like uh
they have let other hostages go during
this time really you think they'll let
them go well i mean the other guys that
they let go they didn't have like a
leveraged thing they wanted they weren't
like oh we'll trade these two guys for
like two guys yeah they weren't an
american magician they were just like uh
we need our american magicians like a
pizza maker or something like that dude
imagine they're like hey look a pizza
maker they're like we want the mind
freak
i think biden would make that trade you
give us chris angel mindfully
we want [ __ ] and liam right now
we're like we'll not give up
he's too hot right now
come on man he's too big of a staple in
vegas crossing a line right now taliban
what about penn teller
yeah you could say
you could take teller this is biden's
actual quote this is what he said he
said the taliban must immediately
release mark before it can expect any
consideration of its aspirations for
legitimacy this is not negotiable
and he's going like this yeah yeah he's
waving his figure out i don't know
anything about the military but i'm
wondering
we're not going to monologue about the
military
let me set it up okay so i don't get
burned
but when they ran away from the
afghanistans right and then all those
weapons all they forgot it there right
the arms donated they never went
whoops let me go back with my [ __ ]
fighter jets and all the millions of
dollars of my own equipment and [ __ ]
get those things back
whoops i forgot it you know like when i
[ __ ] forget something and i go oh my
phone let me drive back and get it you
know especially if like the dudes like
are less armed than i am and they don't
know what the [ __ ] they're doing like
can't you just [ __ ]
kill them
we're gonna leave it here
they just left it peace out
that's true because people are like hey
we got stuff there and they're like i
know
see you later
we're talking about the plane now
but they say see you later and then they
go on tv and they're like
oofy doofies that was uh big time oofy
yeah i just love how short this was like
talked about like that whole move that's
crazy it's so crazy it just was like we
were gonna go back
got lazy like we knew we were gonna
leave it there for six or seven months
we knew we're gonna leave it look the
government is just dumb they're not
corrupt they're just dumb
if you watch the fox news
they're so stupid
they're just so dumb
why is buying so stupid it was that
hundred like hundreds of millions of
taxpayer money and arming the enemies
and yeah it wasn't taxpayer money it was
it was weapons yeah there's [ __ ]
helicopters and planes and [ __ ] tanks
and [ __ ] thousands of rifles shit's
crazy so dumb
we just keep messing up we just keep
messing up oh oh i forgot my weapon
[Laughter]
big goofy doofy
do